la série donc 6 épisodes on les voit
donc chez eux à Los Angeles pour que je
vous résume ça dans une maison un petit
peu vulgaire il y a pas de bibliothèque
il y a pas de livres c'est très
américain tout ça on voit le petit
article qui joue au piano enfin c'est
très americanisé et la première chose
qu'on apprend c'est que tout était
prémédité c'est-à-dire que on découvre
que Mégane en fait depuis qu'elle est en
Angleterre elle fait des stories en
permanence ou dès qu'elle est quelque
part elle a dit qu'est-ce que je suis
malheureux qu'est-ce que je vis malsain
qu'est-ce que ça c'est dur et en fait
elle appelle pas des amis pour dire
qu'elle va mal elle se filme et elle
enregistre ses stories qu'elle ne
diffuse pas ça fait donc un an un an et
demi qu'elle a des stories enregistré
dans son Instagram est-ce que ça veut
dire je pose la question que tout ça
était prémédité qu'elle avait prémédité
depuis un an et demi que tout ça
finirait par des séries et par sortir
Bertrand qu'elle sait depuis que quelle
attaque les équipes de Buckingham le
palais royal qu'elle ne restera pas dans
les Windsor elle a très vite compris que
c'était pas son rôle qu'elle ne
souhaitait pas ça Meghan Markle elle
veut le premier rôle elle voulait être
actrice elle aime la lumière elle
comprend très vite que dans le milieu
Royal la formule royale c'est le seul le
premier rôle ne sera jamais à elle
d'ailleurs à aucun moment vous savez
Mathieu elle ne coupe les ponts qu'elle
a avec l'Amérique même lorsqu'elle est
duchesse de ce sexe elle va garder ses
avocats elle va garder ses équipes
juridiques elle va garder ses
conseillers ce qui veut donc dire selon
moi que elle a déjà l'envie de retourner
en Amérique elle sait déjà qu'elle va
parvenir Myriam n'importe quoi c'est le
fait qu'elle se filme c'est parce
qu'elle veut garder dans l'histoire une
trace c'est quand même l'une des
personnalités
les plus du monde mais qu'elle est dans
une famille historique donc quand elle
se file elle veut laisser cette trace là
dans l'histoire pour que pour que
l'histoire soit le soit le témoin de ce
qu'elle vit pas des jolies choses
assez difficiles donc quand on lit le
bouquin d'Harry franchement excusez-moi
mais qui a été créé
le documentaire tu as trouvé ça très
vrai ça c'est spontané selon toi c'est
naturel peut-être pas Mégane mais alors
Harry je l'ai trouvé
justement avancer sur le sujet qui est
plus la deuxième chose qu'on apprend et
qui est vraiment la plus fort donc il
attaque lui le commonweil je te rappelle
que c'est 54 pays dans le monde et il
dit par coutume on est blanc et
catholique il y a les blancs et les
noirs et il y a des amis qui témoignent
dans le documentaire des amis noirs
aussi à elle et voilà qui disent les
Anglais ont été esclavagistes pendant
des années la Couronne britannique ne
considère pas les Noirs est-ce que et là
franchement je pose la question elle est
pas en train en vrai peut-être de
manière maladroite de moderniser toute
cette monarchie britannique qui en vrai
c'est vrai il y a jamais eu un noir et
qui n'a jamais toléré les noirs ou
est-ce que la monarchie est-elle raciste
en fait
ça c'est s'il y a aucun doute là-dessus
ils ont voulu donner une image
moderne de la monarchie sauf que c'est
on a bien vu avec toutes les embus que
que Meghan a rencontré que finalement
tout tout leur vieux relancer encore et
la preuve c'est qu'aujourd'hui bah ils
ont dû partir aux États-Unis pour
pouvoir vivre tranquillement réécrit
l'histoire alors une cambridats
vous deux parce que là tu as pas été
tracée la monarchie est-elle raciste une
quête Middleton elle met 10 ans pour
parvenir épouser le prince William une
mégane market elle va mettre 13 14 mois
voilà donc on sait très bien qu'ils
avaient deux à l'applaudit des deux
mains ce mariage là pourquoi parce que
ça lui est utile et qu'elle voit en
effet l'occasion de défendre les
minorités pour les Windsor et pas la
liste du racisme
c'est la question
dans les bilans d'histoire de la menace
britannique il n'y a jamais eu
de
la parole
au moment du mariage je me souviens très
bien la dignité de la maman de Mégane on
a tous dit mais quelle femme
extraordinaire sauf et la famille la
très bien accepté c'est parce qu'après
quand on a découvert qu'elle avait fait
de l'abandon d'enfants qu'elle avait la
tête dans les joints tout le temps là
aussi le portrait était beaucoup plus
contrasté et la famille anglaise le
savait elle avait accepté la mère de
Mégane donc quand vous dit dans une
famille où on est de droit divin et de
sang royal depuis des siècles des
siècles oui accepter quelqu'un en quatre
mois et lui montrer de l'amitié on a vu
des images de Mégane et de la reine qui
rit ensemble oui elle avait été acceptée
à l'hôtel le jour de son mariage parce
que son père n'est pas à même de pouvoir
le faire dans le milieu qui était de la
famille elle a voulu faire venir sa
cousine elle a pas pu enfin il y a quand
même là
est raciste pour toi bah une des plus
grandes peurs je suis entièrement
d'accord avec fan des plus grandes peurs
de Buckingham c'est qu'un jour qui est
du sang étrangers qui envahissent le
palais pourquoi Lady Di à peine cachée
malin plaisir de sortir de diele
faillite ça je comprends mais ça allait
emmerder à souhaitons voilà et
évidemment tout le monde se disait
pourvu il y a même qu'on dit qu'elle
avait été tué par les services ceux qui
ont anglais à Paris parce que on risque
un enfant de la Vierge oui enfin
d'accord mais c'est pas on pourrait la 3
jours hein
simplement Mathieu qu'on parle d'une des
plus anciennes famille et histoire
royale du monde ils sont ils
représentent la tradition ils sont
l'Histoire avec un grand H on leur a
jamais demandé d'être hyper moderne
d'être hyper ouvert c'est pas leur job
là des people ce sont des têtes
couronnées
tradition relativement calme encore être
tradition c'est pas forcément être blanc
et moderne c'est pas forcément
accepté ils ont déjà accepté on va
passer la question 3 parce que ben tu es
intéressé Florian elle va être pour toi
aussi alors la question 3 on un truc
incroyable c'est qu'il y a des bureaux
de presse et que du coup pour les voici
les tous ces magazines locaux là-bas
pour pas qu'ils sortent trop de
scandales sur tout ce qui se passe et il
y en a à l'intérieur du Buckingham on
leur donne des orangés donc il y a des
bureaux de presse on leur donne une
petite merdouille comme ça il la sorte
et sortent pas la vérité mais il y a
deux bureaux de presse hein pour William
et un pour Harry c'est ça ce qu'on
apprend et que le bureau de presse de
William qui est beaucoup plus important
parce qu'il va être roi envoie des
saloperies sur Harry pour lui l'abîmer
et ne pas abîmer Buckingham qui le dit
vous le croyez c'est ce que dit Harry
danse
que vous êtes réduite
toi qui connais et puis ensuite Lorient
il le dit c'est vrai ou pas mais mais
alors est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas
il est vraiment au service du palais qui
peut vraiment répondre à cette
question-là avec des preuves à la santé
qui ne peut même pas répondre tu n'as
pas le droit qui constitue ce même monde
et réduit au silence ça va aller
Bertrand ça va aller c'est bon quelle
part s'il vous plaît écoutez-vous parce
qu'en fait l'émission est passionnante
mais quand tu es chez toi sur ton canapé
ça m'arrive quand c'est brouette envie
de changer saoule et de changer pas je
vais répondre à la question de Bertrand
qui est très simple en fait qui peut
répondre à ta question Harry l'a fait il
l'a fait devant les caméras comment il
tombait je finis je finis juste il l'a
fait et tout le monde le sait tu sais
très bien que les journalistes en
Angleterre en Angleterre le savent tous
et lui il est le seul de la famille
royale à ne jamais l'avoir accepté
depuis la mort de sa mère parce qu'ils
étaient très bien que sa mère est en
partie décédée à cause de ce lien avec
les médias avec la presse tu l'as jamais
accepté et aujourd'hui il se venge à sa
façon et c'est même pas c'est pas une
bonne d'État c'est c'est tout simplement
une une façon de donner son opinion sur
un système qui est dépassé et qui est
pourri mais comment peut-on vérifier
cela puisque le palais est réduit au
silence
qui selon moi vraiment sont très
suspects vraiment être remises en
question
en vrai sur ce point-là personne ne peut
le savoir puisque même Harry quand il a
eu cette discussion il lui a posé la
question de dans les yeux à William il
lui a dit est-ce que tu m'as tu m'as
trahi et tu vas balancé des infos
william s'est apeuré lui a dit je te
jure sur la tombe de maman que je n'ai
jamais fait et Harry lui a répondu je ne
sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai l'impression
on va avancer sur des choses on découvre
aussi que malgré tout c'est là qui est
un petit peu plus dérangeant pour Megan
que Megane en fait mais tout ce qui est
un peu rituel en Angleterre salade
salade dérange et il y a un moment très
dérangeant dans le dans le documentaire
c'est qu'elle dit quand on m'a demandé
d'aller voir la grand-mère on m'a
demandé de tout bien faire et puis elle
est assise comme ça devant le
journalisme et elle dit alors m'a
demandé de faire la révérence comme ça
et on sent que ça l'a c'est même Harry
là regarde un peu en disant voilà là ce
sont ce sont nos rituels ça on sent déjà
que elle a jamais vraiment voulu déjà je
sais pas je peux me tromper mais elle
n'a pas voulu
voilà
respecter les règles de cette monarchie
amidon et conscience de l'énormité du
protocole elle a voulu s'y soumettre
mais pas à ce point-là parce que
effectivement c'est un protocole énorme
n'a pas droit de porter faut toujours
porter des collants faut faire la
révérence des choses que elle n'a elle
n'a jamais été élevé avec ses habitudes
là donc
c'est l'amour l'amour a été plus fort
que tout et et les deux c'est pas
possible
elle est tombée amoureuse d'Harry
qu'elle doit aussi subir le protocole
complètement ben non parce que c'est
alors il est suppléant quand ça arrange
la famille en fait mais non parce qu'il
y a un protocole le sait je te laisse
une fois de plus en plus
la mer et le père de ton mari toi c'est
plus compliqué si tu es obligé de faire
des trucs tu dis non c'est comme si on
était la moyenne bourgeoisie mais non
c'est les rois mais j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] de la monarchie mais tu acceptes
les règles ou tu fais quoi
c'est une entreprise les Winners sont
une entreprise
dans une entreprise elle devenait une
employée de cette entreprise à partir du
moment où tu n'accepte pas la politique
d'une entreprise battue nuit entre pas
et tout tu décides d'en sortir ce
qu'elle a fait d'ailleurs
jouer le jeu et dès le début elle a
commencé à elle a commencé à exciter un
peu le protocole et les équipes du
palais en ne portant pas de collant en
refermant elle-même la portière de sa
voiture en portant du verre
et bien quand on est en monarchie c'est
grave monsieur
la menace
je vous coupe tous les deux parce que il
faut quand même avancer un petit peu et
là où je te rejoins pas et leur en toi
qui est si intelligent parfois comme on
peut tout d'abord elle rentre pas dans
une famille elle rentre dans une
monarchie qui est à la tête de 54 pays
c'est comme l'Europe le commonwell pour
faire des échanges marchands elle est
pas arrivée dans la famille de chez
Michel boudeboul qui habite tu vois
la différence entre la monarchie et
Michel bouboule c'est ce que je veux ce
que je veux
amender tu n'impose pas autant de choses
à quelqu'un qui sera jamais reine par
ailleurs elle est juste amoureuse d'un
mec quoi et dire quand on voit le
Sénèque quand on voit le dogue d'Amazon
excuse-moi mais on les voit amoureux et
lui est très amoureux est-ce que je peux
vous dire quelque chose il y a un truc
qui est incroyable évidemment comme le
doc comme le doc est très américain
alors il y a un moment donné elle va on
la retrouve un petit peu c'est Lopez on
la retrouve un petit peu oh on a
retrouvé ton école de jeunesse alors
elle va dans l'école la maîtresse
tu viens tu étais dans ma classe et là
on a retrouvé ton petit cahier quand tu
étais petite fille dessus
je serai riche et célèbre elle avait
cette princesse
riche et célèbre pardon qu'est-ce qui
porte
en veulent être connu sans travailler
gagner de l'argent sans rien [ __ ] etc
je veux dire un truc vous êtes tout le
temps dans la cohérence vous dites que
ce documenté par Harry et Megane à la
fois tu viens de pointer un truc qui
prouve que s'il avait voulu monter
l'opération ils auraient pas laissé ces
petites phrases donc à un moment donné
tu vas tout leur reprocher tout le temps
quoi
elle a écrit qu'on avait 7 ans elle
aimerait être princesse à 7 ans c'est un
scandale il y a une différence derrière
juste en même temps Sophie et après
après c'est toi je te jure Bertrand
tellement de haine et je t'offre un fer
à lister à la fin de l'émission
en fait c'est amusant c'est qu'on dit on
parle de William et Harry en fait on
parle que de leur meuf finalement on
parle de Kate et on parle de Mégane et
de comment elles se sont pliées
effectivement l'une au protocoles
l'autre
quand vous avez dit elle avait quatre
caissières elle était quand même déjà
une star aux États-Unis elle bossait
un rôle de dingue
nulle part non plus mais Yann c'est pas
c'est pas du tout
il y a 4 humains il y a deux stars et
c'est pas ceux qui sont au milieu bien
sûr le charisme de leur père exactement
comme dans les
[Applaudissements]
une toute petite notification lorsque tu
es star internationale et que tu es
lorsque tu épouses une star
internationale tu ne deviens pas star
international non quand tu es prince et
que tu épouses une princesse
tu deviens tu prends le statut de celui
que tu es épouse tu es une femme tu
épouses un prince tu deviens une phrase
mais qui est Christian 2022
en épousant un riz elle épousait aussi
un job je vais te dire parce que toi
alors en fontaine tu as décidé que tu
allais bouger 1000 ans de monarchie
parce que dans TPMP
[Rires]
duchesse
pas alors je peux avancer
j'avance et là vous allez voir c'est
facile hein parce que ce qui moi m'a
beaucoup touché c'est qu'on a vu
évidemment on sait tous souvenus en 97
de voir deux petits garçons qui étaient
très mignons qui étaient derrière le
cercueil de leur mère et on s'est tous
dit ces garçons seront unis à vie par ce
drame or on apprend également ça c'est
dans le bouquin qui est sorti il y a une
interview sur M6 une sur euh américaine
CNN et une sur TF1 c'est l'interview
anglaise il parle de son frère et il
fait une révélation d'abord qui pensent
que ça ne se fera pas et il dit que
lorsqu'il a épousé Mégane et qui lui a
parlé de Mégane ensuite dans la cuisine
William et lui en sont venus aux mains
il dit que c'est William qui l'a frappé
la poussée et il est tombé en arrière
dans la cuisine hier regardez l'extrait
où il en parle
et tout s'est passé très vite si vite
il m'a attrapé par le col déchirants mon
collier et il m'a fait tomber au sol
j'ai atterri sur la gamelle du chien qui
s'est brisé sur mon dos les morceaux
m'ont coupés à live je suis resté là à
un moment étourdi puis je me suis levé
et je lui ai demandé de sortir
viens frappe-moi tu te sentirais mieux
si tu me frapper te faire quoi allez on
avait l'habitude de se battre ça fait
sentir mieux pourquoi vous vous battiez
pour des choses futiles
la différence ce jour-là était le niveau
de colère et de frustration
j'ai parlé de ce que j'avais en moi
pendant tout ce temps
et j'ai vu cette colère en lui
et je peux garantir aujourd'hui que si
je ne faisais pas de thérapie
[Applaudissements]
il y a aussi un moment où vous verrez où
il dit quand il a porté son costume de
nazi c'est son frère William mais qui
lui avait dit ce qu'il est en train de
dire c'est moi on tombe tous dessus mais
en fait c'est William le méchant mais il
parle pas parce qu'il a pas le droit et
lui et lui c'est le genre vous savez
Bertrand va nous dire que ça fait partie
du protocole de t'appeler
tu vas voir d'ailleurs alors vas-y j'ai
un truc je comprends pas que ça ne vous
fera pas il y en a un qui parle qui
parle qui parle c'est les chutes du
Niagara il y a aucune contradiction
d'accord
on pense qu'il ne ressent rien or ils
ont lu aussi cher de la mort de sa mère
ils ont pas le moyen mais non écoute
mais c'est vrai qu'il se plaint tout le
temps il est transparent franchement
mais William il a une histoire de la
gamelle c'est un détail mais ça dit tout
il tombe dans la gamelle
tout est exagéré il se manque de la de
son frère il dit il est plus chaud que
moi il avait une plus grande chambre que
moi il y a des détails qui sont oui
jalouse son frère je dis pas que William
est un saint je dis qu'il y en a qui
pour l'instant ne l'a pas ouvert mais va
camper
tu dis l'autre ne répond pas il ne peut
pas il va être trois on est pas mal qui
répondait pas vraiment attends juste
parce que je te jure il me fait des
descendants d'organes vas-y il est
constitutionnellement réduit aussi en
effet non alors il tombe dans la gamelle
du chien
non pas dans la cuisinière la gamelle du
chat et le chat il s'appelle poula et
c'est une anecdote il a pas donné ce
soir est-ce que le poula qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est le nom de la monnaie du
Botswana pour vous dire que tout monnaie
ismenait tous chez eux un caractère
argent tout tout donc pourquoi est-ce
que ce livre de Saxon 54 pages regorge
de tant de choses ah il va parler de ses
couilles je l'ai aussi on va on en passe
parce qu'il y a 20 millions de dollars
qui sont tombés et qu'il a besoin de
donner des informations et moi je suis
contre ça contre le fait de marchandise
le le côté social c'est intimité royale
que normalement on ne pénètre pas tout
cela pourquoi
je faisais à la base partie du camp du
clan Harry mais j'ai appris récemment et
ça m'a fait changer d'avis que Mégane
avait retrouvé comme par magie son petit
journal intime se créer qu'elle tenait
depuis des années et que ce serait
sûrement l'occasion de faire un nouveau
livre ou une nouvelle série
royale aussi
tu vis grâce à la famille royale
de façon de façon moi toujours très
correcte de façon toujours très polie
parce que j'aime les belles manières tu
vois j'aime la tradition j'aime ce que
c'est incarne et maintenant je te
réponds
un petit connard et j'ai beaucoup de mal
par rapport au fait moi de s'en prendre
à une institution qui ne peut pas
répondre c'est cela alors vous comprend
d'abord pour info celui qui a écrit
libre qui est très bien écrit après 5h
oui après 5 millions d'euros pour
l'écrire c'est alors on appelle ça les
gens qui écrivent ce mot horrible qui
écrit pour les autres
merci Manon dialogue de plume pardon
pour pour ce mot horrible qu'on début
mais il a pris 5 millions d'euros
superbement écrit ça il faut quand même
lui dire le livre on rentre dedans c'est
presque comme un roman et et voilà alors
tu étais drôlement injuste parce que en
fait dans ce livre il a eu besoin de
l'écrire par par souci de vérité ils
s'en sont pris tellement la famille
il va avoir un psy aussi quand la
plupart des people écrivent des
géographie pour raconter tout ce qu'ils
ont vécu ça j'ai une personne là parce
que c'est Harry ça gêne moi je le trouve
extrêmement touchant dans sa démarche et
franchement dire ce que tu dis c'est de
pas considérer que derrière l'aspect
Royal qu'il a il n'est pas un humain et
ça je trouve ça regrettable il nous
parle de lui qu'est-ce qu'on a déjà
savoir par exemple dans le livre que
William et circoncis qu'est-ce qu'il a
besoin de venir lui dire ça qu'est-ce
qu'il nous dit oui qu'est-ce qu'il a pas
de venir nous dire que le jour de son
mariage William était bourré alors s'il
vous plaît
d'abord c'est un vrai sujet parce que
c'est vrai que ça peut rendre plus
sensible ça consiste le premier pas mais
un mot n'a vraiment un mot de vous deux
on passe au sujet d'après mais vraiment
rapide juste on peut quand même rappeler
Carrie est un people depuis le départ il
est plus populaire en Angleterre donc
c'est pas un prince il en a souffert il
a quitté la monarchie donc déjà il a le
droit de dire ce qu'il dit et un truc
très important c'est qu'il a souffert
énormément d'être un people pendant
toutes ces années aujourd'hui il en
profite il fait un livre il fait un dock
il va probablement avoir d'autres
projets qui va mener qu'est-ce qui est
grave alors
réalité qui balance des horreurs sur les
autres comme comme
ça je vous reprends 3 secondes et juste
pour te répondre une minute il dit un
truc un peu touchant il dit on m'a dit
on m'a dit que là je vais le défendre
que j'étais parti sur un coup de tête
c'est là que c'est horrible la monarchie
il a demandé trois fois un rendez-vous
avec sa grand-mère deux fois sa
grand-mère n'a pas eu le temps de le
recevoir j'ai fini par partir c'est vrai
quand ta grand-mère refuse trois fois de
te voir ne serait-ce que 2 minutes c'est
c'est pas ça
s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît vous
allez m'obliger de viril
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est Patrick Sébastien c'est une
très grande soirée de bonhomme juste
après les années Sébastien selon
certains critiques et là c'est bien très
important aussi c'est que on voit que
c'est un éditeur américain qui a publié
livre un nom à l'éditeur anglais
pourquoi jamais un éditeur anglais
n'aurait laissé le passage sur les 25
taliban tués pourquoi en faisant ça
d'abord il révèle il révèle des disques
des indiscrétions militaires et surtout
il excite l'ennemi qui met la monarchie
britannique en danger les Anglais en
danger est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
est-ce qu'il a dit les méchants ont dit
et je vous le dis malheureusement il a
pris le cerveau de sa mère qui est
idiote qu'est-ce que tu en penses
il y a un hashtag qui circule qui a été
partagé à raison de 40000 fois en une
journée shut up arrive ferme ta gueule
Harry si on leur [ __ ] [ __ ]
parce que c'est dangereux en effet que
l'armée britannique a pris la parole et
a dit ce genre de choses là on ne peut
pas jamais jamais on ne peut pas ça une
révélation militaire mais à nouveau je
pense que les Vars
tu peux pas défendre c'est
comme ça
bien sûr le plus grand héros de la
guerre aux Afghanistan aux États-Unis
[Musique]
alors on passe à autre chose s'il vous
plaît parce qu'il reste pas beaucoup de
temps on fait la guerre contre un
journaliste lui demande s'il
réconciliation
effectivement il a plus tiré
de conneries bien sûr que si tu es plus
sur le combat s'il vous plaît
quand Harry quand Joris tu demandes
c'est une réconciliation est possible
pour Harry regardez ce qui répond parce
que encore une fois une chose victime et
ben dit que la balle est dans leur camp
bah oui seul
il n'y a pas de paix sans vérité ma
famille et moi il s'agit de reconnaître
nos erreurs
autour de nous mais tout le reste les
médias doivent rester en dehors de ça
le silence ne permet que les
abuser le silence pourrait arranger les
choses
je vais déposer la question cabertrand
et tu réponds courts est-ce qu'une
réconciliation pour toi est possible moi
je ne le pense pas parce que ce que vous
vous imaginez sous les voûtes de
Westminster où il se retrouverait le 6
mai prochain pour le couronnement de
Charles III le clan Windsor ne rien oser
dire en se disant mais tout va se
retrouver chez Oprah Winfrey ou tout va
se retrouver dans le nouveau livre où
tout va sortir à nouveau je ne pense pas
que la réconciliation parce que de la
part William et le vrai héritier
d'Elizabeth II et pour lui on ne touche
pas à la cour alors j'ai quand même vous
dire quelques petites choses avant c'est
les critiques anglaises sur ce qu'on a
vu sur le bouquin et sur alors voilà ce
que disent des critiques anglaises un
abruti horriblement privilégié et une
actrice de seconde zone ça c'est Pierce
Morgane journaliste anglais il y a la
trahison de Harry feront deux des
loosers narcissique princesse pour y
gâter voilà ce qui a été écrit pire elle
était un virus et non une étrangère à
Buckingham elle joue avec joie le rôle
de sa vraie actrice de seconde zone et
c'est vrai qu'il y a un journaliste qui
lui a posé cette question horrible à la
fin qui lui a dit mais finalement en
balançant tout ça vous préférez l'argent
à votre famille car en Europe on n'a pas
son âge sale en famille et il n'a pas
répondu tu es en train de nous dire que
les journalistes préfèrent se mettre
bien que le futur roi d'Angleterre